As you can imagine, with
everything that's unfolded,
since the senseless
killing of George Floyd,
we're approaching the show
very differently this week.
I had a great conversation earlier today
with W. Kamau Bell,
someone I really respect,
and I'd like to get right to that,
so without further ado,
here's my conversation with W. Kamau Bell.
With what's been going on
in the streets of our
nation over the past week,
I wanted to have a one-on-one conversation
with a friend of our show,
who's not only a comedian,
but a longtime advocate
for racial justice.
He's the celebrity ambassador
on racial justice for the ACLU
and he sits on the advisory
boards of organizations
like DonorsChoose, which raises
money for public schools,
and Hollaback, an
anti-harassment organization.
Please welcome the host of
CNN's Emmy Award-winning
"United Shades of America," W Kamau Bell,
how are you doing?
You know everybody asks that question.
My family's healthy, we're fine,
but we're also getting
feral with stayin' at home
and not going to school and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, well obviously
I wanted to start...
We did a show on Monday,
and I talked to Van Jones,
and I very much wanted to
make that about listening.
But clearly that's maybe
for me the first step,
and there's now so much more to be done,
which is...
I think a lot of us are feeling,
protests are fine but what can we do?
And when I say we I mean all of us.
And people like myself,
what can we do to make
this situation better
in a practical pragmatic way?
Well I mean I think I would, you now,
first I want to make it
clear that when you say we,
let's be clear that I
feel like you're saying
white people as we.
'Cause I feel like Black
people, brown people,
people of color, we have
always done this work,
and we've always had to
figure out what to do,
in situations where we had very little,
I mean if you imagine Conan,
I know it's gonna be hard to imagine.
Imagine being Harriet Tubman,
you know what I'm saying like--
I do that all the time.
(laughs)
I know you were up for the movie, but--
Missed it by that much.
By that much.
Harriet Tubman was an enslaved African,
who had no resources at all,
and had to imagine what can I do?
And you know and now
she's in a rightfully so,
an American Hero,
because in that moment
she just got to work,
and so I think Black people,
especially Black people,
have always had to figure out what to do.
So I really put it on white people to go,
what do you see that you want to do?
I think a lot of times white
people get caught up in like,
being scared of doing it wrong,
and I'm like yes be confident
you're gonna do it wrong,
that's how the work gets done.
You know MLK and his first move wasn't
the March on Washington,
they did a lot of things
to prepare for that.
You're gonna get it wrong white people,
get used to doing it wrong.
You're gonna get do something
you feel good about,
and then somebody's gonna call you out
for doing it the wrong way,
and you're gonna have to get
used to sitting in the space
of like not doing the work right,
but right now a lot of white
people are frozen by the,
I don't know what to
do so I'll do nothing,
and that's why black people get brutalized
by police officers, over and over again,
because white people go,
"Oh that was so bad I feel so bad,"
but then a couple weeks later,
"back to my yoga classes,"
and right now right there's
not going back to yoga classes,
'cause there's a global
pandemic right now.
Right.
There is a sense that right now,
protests are very visual,
this is anyway how I'm feeling.
That you see a lot of people,
and you especially you
see a lot of celebrities
being very visual about their protesting
and then the concern I would think
and rightfully so would be,
this is fine maybe in this moment,
to be visual and to be on the front lines,
but how are you gonna
follow up on this 3, 6,
9 weeks from now, next
year the year after that,
to make America what it should be.
Well I think that's the important point,
because even if you Conan
O'Brien go out to a protest,
you're gonna get a lot of attention,
people gonna feel that,
that image is gonna go
viral all over the world,
you know people are gonna notice it,
but then Black folks are always like,
what's Conan doing in his life?
Right.
And I think right now,
it's very important to connect your life
to the actual movement, and
to the actual making change,
'cause believe me if you said,
Black Americans here's what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna do a complete
internal audit of my show,
I'm gonna ask TBS do the same thing,
of where the Black folks work at TBS,
where other people of color work,
and not give you the
percentage of the total,
but go at what level they are at.
How many your people are the top level,
how many people are at the
at the lowest levels at TBS
and my show.
And I'm gonna tell you that,
and then in a year it's
gonna look different,
and I'm gonna show you
what that looks like.
I'm gonna tell you about my personal life,
like in my personal life how
many Black people I interact
with in my day,
and in a year I'm gonna work
hard to make that look better
and I'm gonna...
Right now we need white
people to show their work.
You know it's not enough to say
I'm gonna read Michelle Alexander's book.
It's enough to go I read it
and here are my thoughts,
it doesn't anybody have
thoughts about my thoughts.
I think right now a lot of white people,
it's easy to sort of like
change your Twitter avi
to a black background,
or to Black Lives Matter,
but eventually you're gonna turn it back
to that wacky picture
you know what I mean?
So we need white people
to not only do the work,
but show their work because we can't trust
that the work's getting done,
because all these articles are written,
blogs are written, the
government's done studies,
the Kerner Commission
released a study that said,
white supremacy is the rule of the land,
and this is why these
things are happening,
but the work doesn't get done.
We need white people to
show their work right now.
Something that's occurred to me,
and I'm sure occurred to a lot of people,
but money in our society is
a very powerful an engine,
maybe the most powerful engine,
where it goes, how it's used.
And yes there's a lot of rhetoric
and the rhetoric is very important,
but sometimes you think,
how am I helping Black owned businesses,
how am I employing people of color,
what are we doing to make
sure that student debt,
student loan and the price of education
isn't leaving out a
huge portion of society
from getting an education.
What are the practical things
we can do now that last.
Mm-hmm.
And--
I mean there's two different,
there's two different things.
There's what can you do that lasts?
But also what can you do right now?
There's the house's on
fire, put out the fire,
and then there's like rebuild the house.
So I don't want people
to get caught up in like,
I can give fifty dollars
here, but what can I do?
Give the money you have
now to support the causes,
and I'm happy to send
you some causes your way,
if you don't know what these are,
but then again it's really about,
how you are in your personal life,
cause if your personal life is correct,
your public life usually is more correct.
If you are personally invested in this,
if you're personally like,
"you know what we don't
have enough Black people
on this show in high positions,
so I'm gonna make sure we go
out and find those people,
and I'm gonna put out a call for this,
I don't have enough Black
people in my personal life
that I'm employing or we
are taking advice from,
I'm gonna change that."
To me it's like, a lot of
this is focused on outside,
and it really needs to focus on inside,
'cause Black people,
we don't do this work for Black people,
And one thing white people
need to get is that,
fighting white supremacy,
being an anti-racist
should be a selfish act,
because if the world is more equitable
and just for Black people,
and people of color,
it's automatically
better for white people.
This is truly the rising
tide that lifts all both.
But I think a lot of
white people feel like,
I'm doing it for them,
I did this for them,
I'm done what I'm doing for them.
And that's why it doesn't,
the work isn't lasting.
Right.
I think especially anybody
who has children knows,
your children and this is for any anybody,
I mean I think about this a lot,
I want it to be a fairer world,
because a fairer and more just world,
is a safer world for my kids.
So that is a way to see,
and if in a very selfish
way, but a very primal way,
if you're a parent who loves your child,
I want my child to be
walking around streets
where the other people
walking those streets feel
that they have a stake in society.
Because then my child's safer,
they're living in a happier world.
So selfishness is not a bad thing,
selfishness is very natural,
and it feels to me that that's--
I think, I think it is I think it
I think describing it
selfishness not those two,
it's helpful to people,
'cause stop thinking like,
I'm doing it because I'm a good person.
As you just said a world that
is more just and equitable,
is better for your kids,
it's a safer world,
but it's also a more fun world.
The best music festivals are the one
that have all the music there.
'Cause it's like, we get
to hang out with everybody,
it's like it's not, it's
not just, a more like
it's not again we get caught
up in the high mindedness
of this, get caught up
in the humanity of it.
Get caught up in the fact that it's just,
it's a more your children
will be more actualized,
they'll have more freedom of expression,
they'll take in more information.
I mean one of the best
things about being a parent,
is getting your kids
to not just eat peanut
butter jelly sandwiches.
Because that's not a good life,
that's not a that's not a life
that leads you down a good direction.
It's about parents are actively
expanding our kids palates
but you have to do the same
thing with your kids brain,
and I'd say I encourage you,
I don't know how old your kids are.
How old are your kids?
I have, my son is 14
and my daughter is 16.
Okay I mean I think it's important
to know what they're reading.
It's important to put both those kids,
you could put the autobiography
of Malcolm X right in their hands today
and they're ready for it.
You know I think it's important to know,
to encourage them to
not just read the things
they wanna read or being assigned,
but really reach out to other sources.
That both those kids can
read Ta-Nehisi Coates.
But then you should read it too,
and then talk to them about it.
But with my kids, with
parents of little kids,
don't - get books that
feature more diverse images.
I'm a big fan of Mo Willems,
big fan of Sandra Boynton,
but also big fan of Selena Alko,
and big fan of Doc McStuffins
and other things that
actually reflect the world,
that my kids can see themselves in.
There's a lot of talk in
the last two/three days,
about Black Lives Matter,
and then some people saying
well all lives matter,
and then people getting very angry
and saying you don't
understand what you're saying,
when you say all lives matter,
even though if you take
that situation in -
or that sentence in and
of itself out of context,
yes you don't disagree with it,
but when you look at it in the context,
that's very upsetting to people,
and I'd like to talk about that,
or hear what you have
to think say about it.
I mean the phrase Black Lives Matter,
is intentionally provocative.
It was a phrase that was
created by three black women,
Opal Tometi, Alicia Garza
and Patrisse Cullors,
in the wake of the Trayvon
Martin murder by George Zimmerman
and it was a declaration of like,
we need people to know Black Lives Matter.
Because at that time and still,
it does not feel like Black Lives Matter.
The criminal justice
system does not put a value
on Black lives,
this education system does not
put a value on Black lives.
So obviously we're talking about,
the police don't put a
value on bBack lives.
So that it's an intentionally
provocative phrase
and here's why.
Because Martin Luther King's
Let's Hug It Out didn't work.
Martin Luther King Jr. was talking about,
"Hey everybody, basically
can't we be friends?"
Rodney King's let's all
just get along didn't work.
So Black people keep raising the stakes
on getting the attention
of white people, you know.
N.W.A had a very effective
we're gonna raise the stakes
to get the attention of of Black people,
I'm not gonna say it
on TBS, but Google it.
So..
Yeah.
Right, Black people's are
basically doing all we can
to get white people's attention,
understand how clear this is,
so if you're bothered by the
phrase Black Lives Matter,
good, now investigate the phrase.
'Cause the fact is all
lives don't matter the same.
If they did we wouldn't have
to say Black Lives Matter,
and nobody,
this is why if you use the
phrase all lives matter,
it is just an attack on the
idea of Black Lives Matter.
And this is how I say that,
nobody ever said all lives matter,
before the phrase Black Lives Matter.
Right.
It was only invented in the
wake of Black Lives Matter.
Nobody was heard going,
I just wanna say all lives
matter, nobody said that.
If somebody had said that,
you'd said are you okay?
Do you need to eat?
(laughs)
Eat some sugar,
you need some sugar and
some carbs right now.
Yeah like that line is like,
even the Beatles who are full of love,
never decided to say that.
It's just not, it doesn't
have any meaning to it.
So for me it's like if you,
I understand what you
get there white people,
but once you get there,
understand why we're not there.
And I think to me,
I would challenge people who,
white people who do understand that,
claim that, you know put that
sign up in your front yard,
put it in your window,
don't just put it on your social media,
make your neighbors see it,
have conversations with your community.
'Cause this is the thing,
we need white people to talk
to each other about this.
There's great organizations out there,
SURJ, Showing Up for Racial Justice.
Which is a white-led,
racial justice organization,
where white people meet with each other,
'cause a lot of times,
you need to have these awkward
conversations with each other
when you're not afraid of
what Black folks are gonna say
or overhear.
So white people need to do this work.
Actually right now Conan,
I'm going to assign you a friend of mine,
to be in charge of your whiteness.
Oh okay,
all right.
Yeah here we go.
I want my assignment, I really do.
I didn't come here just to
talk, I'm giving you homework,
so.
Okay.
Give your kids the
autobiography of Malcolm X,
you read it too, if you haven't read,
it's not you can't just watch the movie,
the movie's great, but read
the autobiography of Malcolm X.
And a friend of mine named Kate Schatz,
who's a white woman who wrote the book,
Rad American Women A-Z,
deals with white people all the time
about how to deal with this work.
So Kate Schatz she's on Twitter,
I'll hook you guys up later,
is now in charge of Conan
O'Brien's whiteness.
Okay, well and also I'm not just white,
I am so (beep) white,
that putting someone in
charge of my whiteness is,
this -- she may decline,
she may that that's too much
whiteness for me to handle.
Believe me you've got enough
public stuff out there,
she's familiar with who you are.
I just called her before this to say,
are you good with being in charge
of Conan O'Brien's whiteness?
She was like (sighs)
She took a knee, and she
took some deep breaths,
but she and she played she
wrote that she did some math,
and she's like I think I can do this,
let me clear--
That's like saying can you bench press?
Do you think you can get to 800 pounds?
Exactly she's like let
me clear my schedule.
(laughs)
She's cleared her schedule
of all other whiteness,
to be of service with your whiteness.
Wow, okay.
Well.
(laughs)
I literally just got
off the phone with her.
All right well tell her
she's gonna probably.
we're gonna have to live together.
Okay that's fine.
She's gonna explain this
is a 24/7 job being here.
You know, I also,
I'm curious about this phenomenon,
I talked about it a bit with its Van Jones
and it's something that
I'm trying to explore
which is how exhausting
it is for Black people
to be explaining their
lives and their situation
to concerned liberal white people,
and how there's a fatigue
that comes with that.
Which is, please tell us you know,
every three months or
two months or one month,
when something awful happens,
it's now become, it's incumbent
on you to explain to me,
what's going on, when
that clearly should not,
why is it suddenly your homework?
It's not your homework.
Well I will say that,
I think that's I accepted
as part of my job,
like this is the I basically
get paid to do this work,
so I accept it.
But the Black guy at work who
makes less money than you,
who you're like I just need
to talk to you about this.
He's not being paid for it,
I feel like a big part of reparations
would just be a government stipend
to give Black people 50% more salary,
just to deal with white people
when racist things happen in the news.
Like that would be, I would
agree to that reparations.
No but it, but also
that, I mean it's free,
what I love about your approach is,
you're a comedian, you're very funny,
so you come up with these
comedic ideas, which are funny,
but also true and you think about,
and you think no, that
actually would make sense,
if there was a stipend for how much,
now I have to spend six
more hours of my week,
explaining racism to
concerned white people,
so I should get $7,000.
Those should be billable
hours, it's like--
Yeah they should be billable.
Yeah exactly.
And I think white people
don't realize that,
because you come to us like,
I'm finally ready to have the conversation
that you've wanted me to
have, and that person's like,
I'm trying to eat lunch for 15 minutes,
and get back to my job.
And if we say we don't wanna
have it then you're mad at,
see this is why we can't
end racism because of you,
because you won't talk to me.
Right.
And it's like and all of this is work,
and it and it's work and
America has a history
of not paying for the
labor that Black folks do,
and this is just a part of that.
Yeah.
The, you know I think
I keep trying to find,
some notes of hope in all of this.
I'm really hoping there are some,
as horrifying and terrible as that video
of George Floyd being killed is.
There was no way not to see it
if you're a white American
and not immediately know
that would never happen to me.
That would not happen to me,
I would never be in that situation,
that I would be treated differently,
and I'm not even just
talking about someone who's
on television.
No.
If I was Conan O'Brien
and I was a spot welder,
who'd no one had ever heard of,
that would never ever happen to me.
And I think that is one
of the reasons why somehow
this feels so seismic.
Yes there have been many
of these situations,
many of these videos,
but I I'm hoping that this one,
and I could be wrong you can
tell me I'm wrong right now.
I'm hoping this one is getting us,
is moving the puzzle piece a little more.
Is that, am I wrong to be hopeful?
I think it's an opportunity for that.
I think, people asked me
if I'm hopeful all time,
I'm only hopeful as long
as I keep doing the work.
So I think a lot of times people feel hope
like something will happen,
like you know cops
kneeling with protesters.
People are like, oh it's gonna get better
because cops knelt with protesters.
But in actuality, a
lot of those same cops,
or cops in those police departments,
are also the cops who are
pepper spraying people,
who are shooting rubber
bullets the people.
In Kansas City, some of the
cops knelt with protesters,
and the mayor knelt protesters,
and then I think it was the same day,
but within 24 hours cops
ran up on a Black man
who was just screaming at them
and using his freedom of speech,
and pepper sprayed him right in the face,
and the people around them,
and then dragged him out,
and all wrestled him to the ground,
in Kansas City, Missouri.
Both those things happened in Kansas City.
So I think if you're looking
for hope, look for it in work,
don't look forward to images or moments.
And I think, the other thing
I would say about that,
the way you feel, the way
that a lot of white people
and you're saying you feel about
what you saw with George Floyd,
a lot of Black people
have felt that repeatedly.
Right.
I mean I look at Eric
Garner was the one for me
that made me just like,
I mean it was a, I mean a lot of it was,
he was a six foot four,
250-pound black guy.
That's my description,
he had asthma, that's my description.
When he was saying, I can't breathe,
I know a lot of that was
because as an asthmatic,
your lungs fail quicker,
and I was like I felt that feeling
of not being able to breathe.
And people called him a gentle giant,
that's been written about me,
so I feel horrible about George Floyd,
and I felt horrible before,
and a lot of black people
felt horrible before.
The thing that makes
this moment different,
Conan and I wanna be clear about this,
white people had more access to it,
because we're in the middle
of a global pandemic,
and more of us are at
home watching the news.
So it's not, I don't think
it's about that specifically,
it's about the fact that maybe before,
the new clip of the Black
person being killed by cops
would've come across your desk,
and you just would've pushed it aside,
or you will watch it once.
But if you're watching the news,
you're seeing it over and over again,
because of the fact our
country at the top level,
has failed with dealing with
the Coronavirus pandemic,
so we're all at home watching the news.
That's uh,
I have nothing to say to that other
than you are a hundred percent correct.
I really do believe that you're right,
that we all of us had to sit and see
that image over and over and over again,
and that is a situation,
that's just the situation
we're in because of Covid-19
but it's too bad, it's a
shame that it took that
for people to really pay attention.
Can I ask you a question Conan?
Yeah.
Do you accept or believe
that this country is
run by white supremacy?
I believe that it's complicated.
I don't believe that that
is the aim of everybody
in this country--
I don't I'm not talking about like,
the aim of each individual
white people you know,
I married a white person,
so I'm not here to be
the anti white person.
I'm just talking about the --
that this country there is
a there is forces in place,
that are institutional and structural,
that just sort of that promote
whiteness over other races.
Yeah, oh yes definitely.
I definitely believe that that is inherent
in the mission statement of
this country historically,
and that it is a, I talked
about this on Monday
that it has been a long
horrible history of us,
and people focus so much on slavery
but it goes so much beyond that,
and I'll also say it's not just
the United States of America
it's a global problem,
I think racism is built in
to many structures around the world.
I believe that in my heart
and I think that the history
of this country is these spasms
of trying to confront it,
and trying to improve it,
and we have these moments
where I think people,
and I'm gonna say be specific,
where I think white people
can feel like we did it,
we got there,
this the first election of Barack Obama,
and then the second one,
had us feeling in a naive sense,
we did it, we're there.
We're not there, you know?
we're far from there,
I don't even know what there is.
I don't, we may never completely be there
because it's like doing,
I like analogies 'cause my brain works,
but when you're working out
or taking care of your body,
you're never there.
It's like what you're talking about,
you gotta do the work,
you don't finish doing sit-ups and say,
I'm done I'm there,
it is a,
and this is coming from someone
who does not do sit-ups.
Let me make that really clear.
It is, this is the work that doesn't end,
it does not end.
So I do think there are moments,
I grew up in a very,
I grew up in Boston,
so it's a city with a
terrible racist history
and racial past,
and still confronts racial problems.
But I grew up in a very
liberal public school system
in the 70s where you know
people are wearing dashikis,
and I grew up with Black friends,
and I really did think racism
of is a thing of the past
and this is in the 1970s.
I really believed that we had,
and this is only ten years after the worst
of the civil rights struggles.
I believed that as a child like,
well at least I think
we took care of racism,
that's because I was
living in a little bubble,
and I was a kid,
and was all I've been my
whole life since then,
and I'm now 57 years old,
has been learning over
and over and over again,
that there's so much to be done,
there's so much work to do,
and being filled with
optimism and then despair.
So that's the cycle,
and yes I think
that America is a work in progress,
is has been my motto.
It is a still a young country,
and it's a country that
has a lot of work to do.
I mean I hear what you're saying,
I think that some people,
I think some people,
there's I've seen a meme going around,
some people saying the
system isn't broken,
the system was designed to do this.
And I think that's what a
lot of Black people feel,
like is like this is actually,
since Black people were
freed from enslavement,
the system has worked hard
to keep us as close to that as possible.
Through not giving us access to the vote,
through not allowing us
to have the same access to a
good education as white folks,
through incarcerating more people
than the rest of the world does,
and more those people are Black
and proportionally should be.
So the system has designed to do this,
so even the fact that the
election of Barack Obama,
the system's response was Donald Trump.
Yes.
And that happens through,
not just like 'cause
Trump is a bloviating sort
of like soundbite machine
and people like that,
it's because through
gerrymandered districts,
through the electoral college
not valuing the popular vote,
the system has controls in place,
for things to be more
inclusive and more equitable.
And I got through I mean
when I say white supremacy,
'cause it's like,
I think a lot of times
white people get caught up
in white supremacists and white supremacy.
A white supremacist is the Ku Klux Klan,
we don't even need to
really be worried about them
for the most part.
They are the mascots of white supremacy.
[Conan] Right.
White supremacy is 44 out
of 45 American presidents
being white men.
That's the system that has,
you think they just those happen to be,
it just having 44 white men who happen
to be the best presidents.
That's the system putting things in place,
like we can't get access to
the Ivy League inner circle
conversations that white people can,
so we don't have the groups,
we don't have people,
we don't have the wealth around us
to fund a race for presidency,
and we don't have those sort of like,
just social circles where
we would wind up in places,
where somebody be like,
you should run for president
and here's on how we're
gonna make it happen.
That's the system of white supremacy,
that is and I think white people need
to be very clear about that.
That's a lot of times white people
will feel very comfortable I don't like
that cop who did that bad thing.
But the system means
that if you become a cop,
you adopt racism or you either adopt it,
or you ignore it, 'cause
that's the other part,
a lot of good cops but there's a lot
of quote-unquote good cops
watching bad cops do that,
and not stepping up and not stopping it.
There was four cops that
could have stepped up
and said stop this, who didn't,
and who may or may not be by the time
this airs maybe they've
been arrested or charged,
but they didn't do anything,
if that they would have been heroes
if any one of them had stepped up,
but cops don't do that.
It's the system of white supremacy
that encourages cops not
just not to speak out
against other cops.
Yeah I think when you
bring up white supremacy,
obviously people go right
to neo-Nazi fascism,
they go to an extreme
rather than understanding
that yes anyone who says the
skids haven't been greased
for white people in this country
is a (beep) moron,
so,
absolutely, absolutely
agree with that belief.
And they have been greased
in both directions,
they've been greased for you to go up
and they've been greased for Black people
to not be able to get any
traction on the way up.
So I think that's the, it's both ends,
and I think that's the
thing we wanna get to,
is that it's both end.
I think a lot of times,
again it's the same thing
you're saying about working out,
if you wanna feel good about your body
and you don't work out that often,
you look at somebody who
works out less than you,
you don't look at the photo of Bruce Lee.
You can you look at somebody--
Right.
And so I think a lot of times,
white people like to sort of,
like to centers the
neo-Nazi, the Ku Klux Klan,
the alright going,
I'm not as bad as that,
so I'm a good person.
Instead of looking at white
people like my friend,
Kate Schatz, or Jane Elliott,
or all these other white people out there
who are on the front lines of the work,
and who are invested in being able to say,
white supremacist rule of the land,
as a white person my
voice is more valuable
in dismantling that system,
because of white supremacy
than a Black person's.
A couple of things,
I wanna make sure that we get the word out
on the causes that you think,
are really gonna help
and make a difference,
and a practical difference,
so that people can be
throwing buckets of water
on the fire now,
and so I wanna make
sure that we post those,
and we put those out on our social media.
I also wanna do everything I can,
my education as a white
man, someone whose,
I wanna make sure that this
person who's taking care of me
and is taking on my whiteness--
Kate.
Kate, I wanna make sure that Kate Schatz,
I wanna make sure that
she's promoted, and--
Yes.
That it's not just my education,
'cause God knows there's a lot to be done,
but that it's everybody's education so--
Absolutely.
So we'll make sure we do that.
Is there anything you wanted to say,
before we end this for tonight?
No I think it's really
important to I first off,
thank you for having me on the show.
Honored to have you, always
honored to have you, yeah.
Yes, so I appreciate the fact
that you're having these conversations,
and all other late-night
show hosts are doing this
at this time,
and it's personally somebody who's not,
I've seen you speak out before,
and you've inspired me before
when you've spoken out.
You know, whether this airs or not,
how you left the Tonight Show,
and what you said about
snark and being mean,
really has stayed with me.
Oh good okay.
And it really helped get,
it helped me get through
a hard part of my career.
So you specifically have helped me.
Well--
So I appreciate you doing this right now.
I love that you came on the show today
and we need to make this a regular gig.
I know you've been on, we've
talked many times before
but we need to keep it going,
we need to keep it going and then
and you're really, it's,
on top of everything else,
you're a very funny man.
(laughs)
And I believe that that's a superpower,
that is a beautiful thing,
especially in times of
real sadness and tragedy.
And you have that superpower
and I'm just, I'm very grateful
to you, in so many ways.
Thank You Conan,
and thank you for using you know,
the word platform is overused
but it's really important
to use your platform,
and like I would just encourage
you to show your work,
you know, to have these conversations,
but also show the changes
that come from it.
It will happen, it will happen.
Well that is our night, that is our,
I think this is the longest
I've ever spoken to anybody,
(laughs)
on any show and you know what,
I just, absolutely loved it.
This is, so thank you so much,
and we will get the word out,
and I will do the work,
and let's all do the work.
Thank you.
Thank you sir.
All right I would do that back at you,
but I'm not sure I'm supposed to.
(laughs)
Well Kate we'll build you up to that,
I'll let Kate handle that.
If you'd like more information
on some of the causes W. Kamau supports,
here are ones that will
help put the fire out now.
LIVE FREE USA ORG,
which provides masks for the black
and Hispanic people
hardest hit by Covid-19,
DonorsChoose, which is helping
disadvantaged children,
with distance learning
and to rebuild the house.
BLACK2THEFUTURE.ORG which
works to enact policies
that improve the lives of black people,
and you can follow the person
in charge of my whiteness,
Kate Schatz,
at @KATESCHATZ.
She's the author of the
Rad American Women series,
and man has her work cut out for her.
You can see W. Kamau Bell's
"United Shades of America"
with W. Kamau Bell,
when it returns for its
fifth season later this month
on CNN.
Good night.